- Welcome back, everybody.
I have one more story to share
from the world of social media.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
May is Asian-American and
Pacific Islander Heritage Month.
It's a time for celebrating
the rich culture and history
of millions of Americans.
A woman in Rhode Island does it
in her own tiny way, literally.
She makes jewelry of
miniature Vietnamese food,
and says it's her way of connecting
with her Vietnamese heritage.
So we have some of her jewelry
in studio. It's so cool.
There are dumplings,
spring rolls, bánh mì,
even a bowl of phở. It's incredible.
Let's get this very
talented woman in here.
Everybody watching on NBC
10 WJAR, say hi to Hana.
What's up, Hana?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- (laughs) Hi to you.
- Hello! Your jewelry is so
beautiful and very detailed,
so how hard is that to make?
- Well, it's definitely a process.
Something like the spring rolls,
they have a transparent
rice paper wrapping,
so I have to use translucent
clay to make them.
Something like the phở has a broth,
so I have to use dyed resin to make that.
And so it's a lot of trial and error.
Luckily, I grew up eating Vietnamese food.
My dad is an amazing cook,
and even though I can't
quite cook like him,
I'm making miniatures that
look just about the same, so.
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, this jewelry is
also meaningful to you,
so can you tell us about that?
- Of course.
So I grew up Vietnamese
in an all-white town,
and as a non-Vietnamese speaker,
the best way for me to
connect with my heritage
was actually through food.
And so what I love about
making these videos
and sharing the process
is that Vietnamese kids
will come into my comments and say,
"My grandmother makes that,"
"That's my uncle's favorite dish."
And having that little moment
of connection with them is really special.
- That's super special!
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much, Hana.
I love it. It's so cool
and fresh and interesting,
the idea, I'm liking your
post right now, all right?
(audience clapping and cheering)
That's not all, though.
Our season-long partner
PILOT Pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
celebrating their heritage
just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Wow, that sounds amazing!
- Thank you, Hana, for joining us!
And thank you to all our guests today,
Priyanka Chopra Jonas,
Max and Bouscher Kovsky,
Emily Crouch, Amy and Dana,
y'all have a great day
(drowned out by audience).